une ferme on soir
dix mille objets au compteur une idée
toutes les 30 secondes un nouveau projet
toutes les 48 heures et donc en moyenne
un avion par jour pour vous rendre aux
quatre coins du monde phillips à vous
êtes devenu l'une des marques les plus
connues de la planète merci d'être là
c'est rare à la télé vous êtes rangs des
fidèles vous êtes fidèle à votre ami de
quarante ans
1976 le journal façade il y avait trois
personnes nées en 49 il y avait philippe
starck jean baptiste mondino thierry
ardisson il y avait deux qui sont
devenus des stars mondiales et inquiète
toujours là
[Musique]
dans ce film ça vous êtes cynique le
plus grand créateur contemporain vous
avez réussi à tour dessinée se vouent
hélas j'aimerais bien alors dernière
fois qu'il est venu c'est dans salut les
terriens il ya huit ans et on va voir
pour commencer ce que vous avez fait
depuis 2008 donc ses hôtels mama shelter
au début il y en avait un à paris et
puis maintenant il y en a à paris à lyon
à bordeaux à marseille à los angeles il
va y en avoir 50 en 2020 c'est quoi le
concept pourquoi ça marche non à celle
tasser avant tout le respect c'est à
dire que c'est un endroit où on respecte
les gens qui eux aussi ne peuvent mettre
que 100 euros la nuit parce qu'on est
dans une société où on respecte beaucoup
ce qu'ils peuvent mettre 1000 euros la
nuit oui tandis que là on dit que c'est
pas forcément des cons alors ça c'était
2008 2010 l'hôtel royal monceau ça c'est
pour ceux à 10000 la nuit ouais c'est ça
ils sont vraiment extraordinaires c'est
la nuit vous avait démoli l'hôtel ouais
j'y étais tu étais ouais c'était
dangereux mais il ya un début décembre
un incendie il y aurait pu y avoir 50
malawi ah oui on est passé très près
pour être la cata cette année là en 2010
vous avez fait une box qui très célèbres
dont je peux pas dire le nom
clé parfaite pendant l aile dure en tout
cas il ya eu aussi le photomaton du
métro parce qu'il fait toi c'est vous
qui avait dessiné le photomaton du métro
ouais redessiné c'est pas très compliqué
je suis fan et du net voilà mais à lille
a fait que d'être géniaux alors en 2011
à une poubelle range qui s'appelle élise
pour collecter les papiers usagés dans
les entreprises et c'est surtout pour
réintégrer des gens qui en avaient bien
besoin donc c'est win win win c'est à
dire qu'on range son papier on recycle
le papier il ya des gens qui retournent
pas en taule ça compte pas mal ça
alors nous refuser de travailler pour
des marques d'alcool de tabac de pétrole
vie j'ai travaillé pour les églises des
religions mais une charte éthique un oui
et c'était fait étrangement il n'est pas
content mais pas beaucoup de ça puisque
ma compagnie doit voir près de 40 ans à
40 ans le moto était fiq le mot éthique
on sait par trou flûte rethel et on l'a
suivi et je peux vous dire c'est un gros
budget tout l'argent qu'on perd après ça
en 2012 effet le pass navigo web assez
pour anoblir le moyen de locomotion réel
de millions de gens et donc décidé d'en
faire un objet de luxe ce petit bout de
plastoc était luxe veut vous avez la
voiture électrique volt et ys oui bon
c'est une voiture électrique qui
sommeille méhari un peu ça ressemble
juste au minimum que devrait être en
permanence l'automobile l'automobile est
un véhicule qui sert peu qui devrait
beaucoup me servir mais qui est entourée
d'une énorme coquille de merde
simplement pour promener les goths la
prétention l'agressivité le machisme là
on a tout enlevé rskp siège 4 où ça
marche aussi bien
le casque sic pour parrot zikmu parrot
est un très bel exemple
du de la french touch en électronique
avec ce génial henri seydoux et sa
compagnie ou là il ya vraiment de
l'intelligence artificielle
ccc où on est au début du bio nisme
c'est à dire que quand un objet et qui
est encore un peu à l'extérieur de vous
mais les rapports avec à passe de
caresses comme ça je monte le son je
change de disque vient comme ça c'est
inouï on est dans le début de l'harmonie
entre le corps est l'objet j'avais fait
venus le lieu de steve jobs alors là
vous alliez un week-end par mois 1 palo
alto à l'époque où steve jobs était
malade ouais franchement mourant même
mais franchement mourant set en sept ans
de travail avec un monstre est aussi
d'intelligence problème on suit avec les
héritiers
de steve jobs qui voulaient pas payer
les demandes et là c'est incroyable on
vit avec une famille pendant 7 ans ont
des de la famille papa mort
le bateau est finie on envoie la
dernière facture et on la voit jamais et
là on fait avec qui j'ai vécu pendant
sept ans et la réponse c'est des
américains
en 2014 j'ai eu la maison paf donc
préfabriqués 100% écolo avait toujours
dit moi je me souviens des l'époque vie
les gens vivent dans des grottes en fait
mais les appartements cédés grotte un
oublié faire autre chose bah ça cette
année la maison des 3 suisses des
élections un succès formidable non ça
c'est un essaie vraiment de mai
industrialisés écologie qui produisent
plus d'énergie qu'elle n'en consomme ça
m'est venu le jour où j'avais besoin de
maisons de campagne parce que mes
enfants s'accumulaient il me suit ne
vais pas l'acheter une jolie maison à
montfort l'amaury si mes enfants dans
puits de pétrole pour la chauffer donc
il faut que ce que je lègue maintenant
soient autofinancés par l'énergie
renouvelable et voilà
alors j'ai fait des tongs et ouais bah
oui bien sûr parce que je voulais
toujours faire des chaussures ça manque
à ma panoplie est donc comme on voyage
hélas beaucoup avec ma petite femme
monsieur perçu comme que la chaussure le
plus porté dans le monde c'était la tong
en 2016 elle fait encore un yacht le
white pearl ouais bah ça c'est le plus
grand voilier de l'histoire de
l'humanité c'est un voilier gigantesque
aile la librairie est grande comme
studio sur trois étages corps c'est le
plus grand musée d'art moderne flottant
du monde et c'est surtout le plus grand
laboratoire de recherche jamais fait sur
les technologies nouvelles pour la
marine c'est un truc est très très
impressionnant c'est une sorte de
monstre marin incroyable mais de là va
sortir des des milliers des milliers des
milliers d'applications pour des plus
petits bateaux la tête et paient
[Applaudissements]
et alors une prostate géode bah c'est
pas mal ya plein de gens qui en meurent
parce qu'ils comprennent pas qui à un
moment ils ont un petit peu mal là et ce
mal là-bas et ça leur donne à peu près
deux mois devant eux ouais donc on a
fait un gros machin gonflable pour
sensibiliser pour expliquer aux gens ce
que comment elle a enchaîné une pensée
et aujourd'hui donc à une collection de
parfums donc c'est tout premier parfum
alors évidemment c'est pas seulement le
le contenant c'est un vrai parfum vous
avez fait un emballage les faits non non
non c'est surtout le juge ça ça fait
c'est une histoire je vous le racontez
ça prend que deux heures mais avant
quand une dame divorce est dans la
bourgeoisie française les parents
devaient l'occupé et donc les parents de
ma mère lui avait acheté une parfumerie
ma femme ma femme ma femme est très
belle oui mais ma mère aussi était très
très très très belle et je n'ai pas que
ça à foot de tenir une boutique et donc
moi je n'ai pas que ça à foot d'aller à
l'école donc j'étais le vendeur de la
boutique mais c'est un trou perdu et
personne et donc j'ai pris l'habitude
tout petit j'avais 7 8 ans d'aller dans
la réserve derrière de monter sur les
étagères de rester prostré sur l'étagère
des heures et des heures
totalement défoncée par toutes les
étapes les alcools les odeurs des
parfums des shampoings et c'est là où
j'ai compris ce qu'est à territoire
mental c'est là où j'ai compris que
quand on est vraiment dans la détresse
absolue la seule possibilité c'est de
rêver c'est de créer et là on a fait
cette collection est là encore quatre en
a discuté on n'a jamais parlé de 60
laurent il faut qu'elles sont des choses
comme ça on parlait de
qu'elle serait l'odeur du vide ah ouais
qu'elle serait l'odeur de la vitesse
qu'elle serait l'odeur du temps il a la
bonne 2-1
même pas toujours à jeun et cette année
en plus du parfum vous avez redessiné un
smartphone c'est extraordinaire parce
que l'écran recouvre toute l' entière de
la surface du smartphone c'est surtout
intéressant parce que là on est à la fin
du design il y à un bloc de céramique
noire massif y a plus de trous ya plus
de boutons il ya qu un écran basta cosi
et la galère pour le designer c'est
alors monsieur stark les prochains ils
sont comment oui comment quand je remets
des dorures
et là on est vraiment dans la fin de
quelque chose c'est à dire que le design
abouti intelligent honnête visionnaire
et on peut plus faire moins pour
certains produits cette extraordinaire
vous avez en avant la fin de la matière
nous sommes enfin passer dans la
dématérialisation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très heureux d'être votre ami e c'est
très réciproque un mois les deux petites
tables
alors philippe vous était le 18 janvier
1949 non ça c'est pas vrai je suis même
6 mais c'est pas vrai nom plein alors
votre maire était une fille à papa très
joli et votre père est un constructeur
d'avions il a fait le premier avion de
tourisme lancée après la guerre qui
s'appelait le starck as 20 c'était un
inventeur tout à fait vrai il avait
inventé les revêtements de bateaux
antidérapant le rouge à lèvres le tube
de rouge à lèvres s'enroulant this way
en réponse que je serai riche maintenant
mais c'est quand même un homme qui avait
construit son premier avion à 12 ans ah
ouais quand même alors ce qui est
extraordinaire chez vous c'est que vous
passez les premières années de votre vie
sous la table de dessin de votre père il
jetait ses feuilles vous étiez sous le
bureau comme ça et vous voyez ce qu'il
faisait et un jour j'allais chez vous et
j'ai vu des feuilles de calques qui
étaient épinglés sur définit donc comme
ça et sur ses feuilles de calques il y
avait des courbes dessinées au crayon je
vous ai dit mais c'est pourquoi à ses
courbes je sais pas encore c'est des
courbes vrai je regardais jaillette
comprendre le sa part est prétentieux
mais le signifiant de ses courbes la
dynamique pourquoi le cx ce qui est donc
le rapport d'aérodynamique et exprimer
la dynamique et après j'en ai sorti
beaucoup d'objets et votre père
disparaîtra très vite de votre vie mais
ils vous laissent quand même en héritage
l'habitude et le devoir de créer quand
même oui oui j'ai appris avec lui que
pour qu'un avion vole il faut le créer
pour éviter qu'ils se cassent la gueule
il faut être rigoureux voilà et donc
c'est les deux lignes et après je suis
devenu un petit peu autiste je suis
resté gt rien je passe je fuyais
j'allais pas l'école j'étais vraiment
vraiment au fond du trou vraiment
vraiment ailleurs ma mauvaise ailleurs
et avant de me jeter par la fenêtre je
me suis dit que finalement c'était
peut-être un petit peu idiot il fallait
que j'arrive à à jarry vrai que j'arrive
à exister que je comprenne la société
que j'avais pas con prix parce que je
comprenais pas l'école et je me suis pas
la seule chose que je sais faire
finalement c'est créer à l'âge de 16 ans
c'est sur les conseils d'un amende de
votre mère il vous trouve efféminé le
mec et il dit bon comme il est effet mis
on va en faire un décorateur exact c'est
jacqueline comme ton fils va être payé
autant qu'ils soient des corps at
on fait quoi faire ils ont essayé ils
ont essayé alors les destinations labs
envoyer à l'école missile de camondo
donc vous avez appris n'ont pas grand
chose non j'avais avant simplement là
j'ai appris qu'il y avait d'autres gens
sur terre voilà oui et des gardiens ça
vous a un peu spécialisés voir le
problème avec les filles si vous étiez
totalement invisible c'était mignon
j'étais bien élevé j'étais bien habillé
j'avais une voiture de sport rien c'est
comme ça et ce n'est pas ce qui est
marrant d'ailleurs c'est qu'à l'époque
pour exister comme l'homme invisible ces
thèmes et les bandelettes ou craven
arbre de noël n'est pas un arbre de noël
tant qu'il n'a pas les boules et les
guirlandes là vous dites je vais faire
des trucs pour exister c'est ce que j'ai
fait ouais alors j'existais tellement
peu j'étais telle ou telle panique telle
détresse que c'est comme les dessins
animés vous savez y aller le type qui
est ce qu'ils se noient et il va faire
le var et il continue il n'a pas lillois
pas qu'il est hors de l'eau qu'il est
dans un bien mauvais et ce exactement
c'est là où je suis aujourd'hui c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque c'était dur pour vous
on se moque êtes vous quand même et
sauvage s'était fait l'avocat le curé
ouais la gonzesse très quand on est
quand on est totalement
à sociale mais sans le savoir sans être
un rebelle j'étais super gentil superflu
sans que j'avais pas du tout du tout les
codes c'est affreux
aujourd'hui vous êtes riche et célèbre
vous êtes assez riche pour ne pas savoir
combien vous gagnez
bas c'est peut-être une des seules
raisons de gagner de l'argent ouais
c'est pas vrai a calculé en fait vous
rêvasser je suis un arrêt vasseur
professionnels rêvasser toute la journée
un trait de votre femme ce très
important à fabrication
laval occupe 90 % de mon cerveau
aggraver nos mais je ne pourrais pas
areva c'est tout le temps je ne pourrais
pas totalement en dehors de la plaque je
pourrais pas totalement une boule de
cristal s'il n'y avait pas ma femme qui
avait un petit cordon ombilical et qui
me permettait quand même d'arriver
encore un communiqué sans ça je serai
totalement autiste aux fanas d'un trou
madame je suis je suis je suis à moi
demain vous rêvez assez dans une
douzaine de maisons quand même oui mais
ça c'est professionnel parce que j'ai
besoin de voir la mer je voudrais voir
la forêt les dunes géré en fonction par
exemple sur vous confie un boulot vous
dites je vais aller dans cette maison du
camp allié que là je vais trouver l'idée
à sète on ne s'est pas trouvé l'idée si
le niveau de concentration
c'est à dire que j'ai des maisons où il
ya des amis donc jette un petit peu
distrait il ya des maisons il n'y a plus
d'un demi milliard des voisins à qui je
veux dire bonjour ayant des maisons il
ya plus rien du tout ouais et donc
suivant le niveau de complications je
vais ou plus loin possible où on reste
un mois deux mois sans sans parler sans
rien dire sans eau sans électricité
oui mais on est très content
[Musique]
alors vous aviez déclaré vouloir arrêter
à l'âge de 50 ans c'est raté c'est raté
pour plusieurs raisons c'est que
il y a eu ce président américain bush
qui a mis le feu à la terre c'est à dire
qu'on commençait un petit morceau de
civilisation civilisé quand ce criminel
de guerre a mis le feu et une a fallu
tout revoir à ce moment là des problèmes
sont arrivés des nouvelles nécessités il
a fallu continuer tout a été chamboulé
et on y est encore on arrive toujours
pour éteindre le feu on n'arrive
toujours pas à répondre aux questions
donc on y est toujours et je pense qu'on
en a encore pour un bon paquet de temps
vu les dernières nouvelles oui dette
inquiète comment ne pas l'être à ce que
je connais bien je connais c'est
vraiment c'est pire que ce qu'on dit
le groupe problème c'est que
il n'a jamais voulu être élu il voulait
faire une énorme opération de pub le
problème c'est qu'il ne sait plus quoi
faire il est assez intelligent pour
comprendre qu'il ne peut pas faire ce
qu'il a dit et il est dans une panique
totale et quand les gens me disent
qu'est ce qu'il va faire limin le sait
pas lui même il ne le sait pas le mec
j'aimerai pas être le matin dans l'île
doit être en sueur en disant mais bordel
qu'est ce que j'espère c'est incroyable
phil hughes merci on vous laissera
partir les corrections de ne rien rater
le in a l'habitude abonnez vous il
mettait un peu de bleu